- The amount of people in here
that have a job they
hate and they buy things
they don't care about to impress people
they don't give a fuck about
scares the shit out of me.
- [Man] Many of us have to do things that
we don't actually like or love
but deep inside we have something
that we really want to do
but we can not do because
of the responsibilities
and you know we have to
have the stable income,
we have to do something because
we have to but don't love.
The question is, what
are the three activities,
the three main goals that you have to set
in order to move a step closer towards
doing something that you actually love?
- So it's a really interesting question
and as I was listening,
and I hope people were paying attention.
Most people spend money on dumb things
which then forces them to
do things they don't want.
So step number one for
most people in here.
They should sell their home,
take the money and go rent.
They should return their
BMW and get a Toyota.
- [Man] I own a BMW. It's not that bad.
- And honestly, that
becomes the vulnerability.
Why do you own a BMW?
- [Man] Because I love the car,
'cause the branding,
I love driving it.
So I don't know.
- So to me that's where it
gets interesting, right?
Do you or do you like what the brand does
to make you look to other people?
I don't know. I'm not
assuming. I don't know.
- [Man] You have a
point. You have a point.
- I know I have a point.
I don't know you, but I know in the macro
that 98% of people that
buy a Mercedes or BMW
likes what it makes other
people think of them,
not that they like it
and that $487 a month
versus what they really
need which is $100 a month
is why they have a job they hate
because they're paying for
a life that means nothing.
(audience clapping)
The amount of people in here
that have a job they
hate and they buy things
they don't care about to impress people
they don't give a fuck about
scares the shit out of me.